[Music]
we are surrounded by air from all the
directions this envelope of air around
us is what we call atmosphere does air
also exert pressure on objects on the
earth in our previous video we studied
that the liquid exerts pressure in all
directions for example here we have the
water in a beaker due to gravity this
water is pulled down towards the earth
if we divide this water into different
layers then each layer is being pulled
on by the earth due to this pool water
exerts downward pressure and this
pressure is uneven throughout that is
the bottom layer experiences more
pressure than the top layer this is
because the weight of water above the
bottom layer is more and the pressure
decreases as we go upwards in fact we
thought that the water exerts pressure
in all directions and not only in the
downward direction one more thing that
we studied about the liquid pressure is
that at any point in a liquid the
pressure is the same in all directions
that is if I take any point here in this
water the pressure exerted by water here
is the same in all the directions a also
behaves in the same way just like water
air is also being pulled down by the
Earth's gravitational force this force
applies pressure on the air in the
downward direction the pressure exerted
by air is called air pressure or
atmospheric pressure did you note that
the atmosphere is divided into different
layers the atmosphere is divided into
five layers namely the troposphere
stratosphere mesosphere thermosphere and
exhaust via the pressure in the
troposphere which is the bottom most
layer is higher than the pressure in the
layers above it can I'm sure you can
guess the reason why this is because the
weight of the air above the troposphere
is greater than the weight of the air
above biggest stratosphere
the air pressure also asks in every
direction and not only in the downward
direction and finally just like the
pressure in liquids the air pressure at
a particular height above the Earth's
surface is same in all directions that
is if I take these two points at the
same distance above the Earth's surface
then the air at this point will exert an
equal pressure in all the directions
just like the air at this point let's
look at an interesting graph now a graph
which represents pressure at a
particular attitude the graph also
represents how to pressure varies from
layer to layer the troposphere layer
it's closest to the surface of the earth
and the pressure in this layer goes up
to 100,000 Pascal where Pascal's
represented by PA is the SI unit of
pressure this is massive pressure this
pressure pushes and pulls the object on
the surface on the earth for example if
I take a table with the upper surface of
one by one metre the pressure exerted by
the air on the table in the downward
direction is greater than 1 lakh
Pascal's this is equivalent to 10 cars
being put on this table
yes 10 cars I know what you must be
thinking why doesn't a surface collapse
under this huge pressure how does it
handle such massive pressure acting down
on it a little while ago we said that
the pressure exerted at points above the
Earth's surface is equal in all
directions so the pressure at every
point on the table is the same in all
the directions
that is if downward pressure is pushing
the table surface with a great force
then the Erfurt pressure is also pushing
it in the upward direction with the same
force both the forces are balanced and
the table does not collapse as I said
pressure is not only acting in these two
directions it is acting on the surface
in all the directions
pressures acting in opposite directions
cancel each other out here is one cool
experiment that you can also perform at
home take a plastic bottle filled with
water take a cardboard paper and place
it on the open end of the bottle like
this holds this paper with your hand so
that it does not move from its position
and invert the bottle now let's go off
the paper what did you see the cardboard
paper sticks to the surface why is it
held to the surface it is held to the
surface because of the air pressure that
is pushing the paper in the upward
direction the upward air pressure is
sufficient to counter the downward push
exerted by the water now make few holes
in the bottle at its base what happens
now why did the paper fall off 50 upward
pressure on its top acting or did it
reduce in the value
no it didn't the upward pressure on it
by the air remains the same but the
downward pressure increased in its value
when we made holes in the bottle we
allowed air to flow inside it from the
top the air from the top started
exerting pressure on the water
the combined pressure of water and air
from top could easily overcome the
pressure exerted by air from the bottle
hence there is net force acting on the
paper in the downward direction that is
there is more pressure in the downward
direction that is the reason why this
paper gets detached from the surface
you
[Music]